suzanne goulet marche quatre fois par
semaine
cet hiver elle le fait à l'intérieur
pour une raison bien simple je veux rien
cassé pour pouvoir faire de
l'entraînement ou de l'exercice dans un
environnement sécuritaire
ces cardiologues appelle ça de la
médecine environnementale
une approche qui lui est cher les
médecins ont une mauvaise connaissance
de ce que le climat peut influencer
leurs patients selon sondage réalisé par
l'institut national de santé publique du
québec et de l'université laval
65% des médecins affirment que leur
formation ne les a pas préparer au
changement climatique
l'institut veut les sensibiliser
radio-canada a obtenu copie d'un
document rédigé par quatre médecins et
chercheurs qui sera bientôt mis à la
disposition de la population et surtout
des professionnels de la santé
quels sont les manifestants les effets
des changements climatiques sur le
système respiratoire quels sont les
effets des changements climatiques sur
le système cardiovasculaire les
inondations peuvent avoir des effets sur
la santé mentale
les vagues de chaleur augmente le nombre
de décès et la glace sur le sol augmente
le nombre de fractures
les changements brusques de température
en hiver peuvent tous et avoir des
impacts un changement de température de
12 15 degrés ans dans quelques jours
notre corps est pas capable de s'ajuster
même plus leur pour le commun des
mortels fait que les personnes déjà
fragilisées c'est encore plus difficile
une diminution de la température
hebdomadaire moyenne de 10 degrés
celsius augmente le risque
d'hospitalisations ou de décès de 7%
une autre étude citée dans le document
révèle qu'une diminution d'un degré
augmente le nombre de décès par maladies
respiratoires de 3 3% l'environnement
changement climatique à vaincre les gens
pelleter je prends je prends deux
pelleteuses les gens pelt elle faisait -
58 neige faisait moins 5
là il fait moins 1000 un cas qui fait
très froid quand les gens peuvent dont
le pelletage c'est un stress plus rock
appuyons le froid lien et spéculent
recommande aux professionnels de la
santé de questionner l'environnement de
leurs patients est-ce qu'ils travaillent
à l'extérieur est ce qu'il demeure dans
un îlot de chaleur dans un logement
auprès d'une usine par exemple parce que
les climat et la santé sont intimement
liés ici marie laurence de l'année radio
canada montréal